anna what's going on how can i help what
is an appropriate way
to end relationships specifically
friendships
that detract from your personal or
professional
growth so it's a broad topic yeah
it's funny i was just talking to some
buddies the other day like we don't have
like grown up
like you don't have breakups with your
regular friends right you only have
breakups with romantic friends we don't
have like a
a cultural system for saying like i
don't want to be your friend anymore so
please never
we don't have that right we just quit
returning their calls basically um
exactly and i don't want to do that okay
so you have you have something going on
so tell me what's actually happening in
your world like put a put a context for
this
yep so i've got like lots of beautiful
people in my life and even the ones i'm
trying to end
relationships with they're also great
people
but they've kind of there's a there's a
couple of them who've
put me on this pedestal almost and have
become very obsessive
and demand a lot of my attention and
time okay
and i've tried setting boundaries
they're not respected
and so i just want to figure out how to
end it give me an example of you set a
boundary
and they didn't respect it what does
that look like oh wait
so i took my medical boards a couple
months ago
i took it i passed yeah dude way to go
all of america just cheered we only have
like 32 listeners but we're all cheering
for you
that's so good awesome and these are
your boards for med school
huh these are your med school oh
congratulations that's so cool
way to go right and you as you
understand they were incredibly
exhausting like you're in a hole for
months studying
um and afterwards i had told everybody
like hey
i'm gonna lay in my bed for like three
days
not to respond to anybody right well
deserved
and like one of the people was
just so happened to be 30 minutes away
from her home in my neighborhood
it just like showed up so things like
that and it's like i made it clear i
need alone time
in my bed yeah so is
is that enough that you want to end
relationships or are you about to move
across country
like when you say i want to end this
thing what does that mean
you want them to never call you again
i guess not but i don't know how to set
the boundaries
like i would be there for anybody if
even if like some stranger broke down on
the side of the road you know
and they're like hey you help and i
would of course um but hey it's
way way easier to help strangers than it
is to help
people that are in relationship with
right
right and they are good people because
if they were a juror it'd be easy to end
right but it's like if i give them an
inch they keep
trying to take a mile and i'm it's just
exhausting even telling them no
all the time um so and when they ask
a lot it's like eventually you say yes
and then you just drink
they wear you down what kind of doctor
are you going to be
um so i want to go into endocrinology
okay
that's the path and for those who don't
know what that is
give them a 30 second primer on
endocrinology
um so i want to so it's like a little
bit unconventional but i want to help
people so as a personal trainer and
nutritionist prior so i want to help
people
with lifestyle changes to balance
hormones
but overall give hormones as needed
to get people into balance and then
change behaviors excellent
so there's two things at play here
number one i think there's a part of you
that loves loves
loves being the go-to person in your
community
and i know that because i'm the same way
and it's exhausting too is that fair
yes and so it is super cool to have
people reach out
ask questions my guess is you've always
been the smart one in your crew you've
always been the fun one that will do
crazy things you've been in med school
you've been everybody's token med school
friend
right and
that also comes with a cost because they
call you at all hours of the night hey
you look at this weird mole what do you
think about this
is coveted real like you do that all the
time right
exactly um and so
it's exhausting also and it's especially
exhausting when people think they have a
friend who's a doctor
or a mental health person or a finance
person
um their emergencies always has to be
your emergency right
and so they call all the time what is it
about you
that won't just turn your phone off like
you make this announcement i want a
three-day
sabbatical from earth why didn't you
just turn your phone off and not answer
the door
yeah that's a good question it's because
i tell people like
it's because i'm not gonna it's because
you kind of liked it
and yeah you wanna be connected but you
wanna be connected on your terms and
those aren't real
boundaries those are pretend boundaries
right or i call them indignant
boundaries
um it's where i will
go by i don't i'll come up with some
terrible analogy here
they're just indignant boundaries right
there they're screen doors they're not
walls
and then i want to be able to see out
there and make sure everybody's doing
good make sure i'm still important
but when you call them like what are you
doing why are you right
and so i would say when you put up a
boundary
you have ownership there it's your
responsibility to draw that line a
and then hold that line because people
are going to test and see if that
boundary
it holds firm or not and if you're
um this is cool that you're learning
this on the front end of what's about to
be a long journey
to become a licensed medical doctor
because it's going to just get crazier
for you you're going to be this way for
everyone in your community
you're going to have friends of friends
who call you right
this is just going to be your life and
so when you
set a boundary then you are then
responsible for making sure that wall's
firm
right it really bugged my
buddies when i would start turning my
phone off on the weekends
it bugged me more and then
quickly everybody kind of just learned
right and now
i i'm not so militant about it and i'm
kind of sad that my friends don't call
me on the weekends
but i set that boundary that's me right
i set it up right
so that's number one it's super annoying
that you put that out into the universe
i don't want anyone to check on me
but my guess is you've set up boundaries
like that before and then people show up
and you're like oh come on in
and you have coffee and ice cream
together and you all hang out and have
some laughs
they leave and then you get indignant
about it so i would say
you put it out they violated your
boundary but you opened the door they
showed back up
so if you want to have those boundaries
draw them here's the second thing
you are entering into a profession where
the crux of your success in this
profession is not going to be academic
there's a lot of smart people it's not
going to be the information you quote
unquote have in your head
it's going to be how you communicate
hard truths to people in a vulnerable
and exposed way
and let them hear and listen to you
not be devastated by you and then know
you love them but then they've got to go
make behavioral life changes right right
this will be most you you'll be most
successful in this
if you can have some congruence which is
the nerd rogerian word for
i'm the same person at home as i am at
work as i am at
the store as i mature the more you can
be the same person
the better right and you know where i'm
going here
the more you can sit down with one of
your friends who you love and say hey
look i'm
taking a three-day sabbatical from life
for sure don't call me i'm gonna turn my
phone off i'll love you
or if they show up and bang and ring the
doorbell ring the doorbell ring the
doorbell
you meet him at the door and you say hey
i
seriously i love you but this is some
sacred time for me
and i can't hang out and i know it's
gonna be super frustrating but i don't
want to so i'll give you a call in two
days after my sabbatical with life is
over
and you shut the door in a gentle
compassionate loving way
and then if they sit there and honk
their horn and they
air horn out your window that's when you
call the police on him and say i have a
crazy person in my front yard right
but all that to say is learning how to
have these compassionate
but direct loving but hard conversations
which don't have to be a production they
don't have to be a show
they're just simply here's my boundary
here's my truth and you're not
you're not i don't like that phrase my
truth because there's
we weaponize that but here's my boundary
and you're not
i've asked you two or three times to not
text me after 10 o'clock
and i turn my phone off and you keep
texting you keep calling you keep
knocking on my door
why do you keep violating my boundaries
right that's that's this that's going to
be the
an easier version of five years from now
when you sit down and say
hey you have thyroid cancer and we're
going to take this out and you're going
to have to have some exogenous
hormones for a season and you're going
to have to really change your diet or
you're gonna die
right that's that's just a precursor to
that conversation
so let's practice really quick so
give me a new boundary in your life okay
i am i'm a new boundary in my life
yeah i will not answer the phone i'm
gonna say
after 7pm because i go to bed early
dude you just made mine you just made my
heart feel good
doctors they get a full night of sleep
change lives everybody
so um okay cool so i'm just gonna knock
on your door
hey uh anna what's up let's go party
there's some super cute fill in the
blank it's fill in the blank and
the show starts at nine you're coming
and then i open do i not open the door i
don't know
you you're the grown up here you're the
one who's about to be a doctor
you tell me yeah if i hear them talking
about
so i open the door uh hey sorry
i told you i'm turning my phone off at
seven i don't want to leave let's back
up
no need to apologize you've already
stated right
they should apologize to you for
violating your boundary
true so hey i asked you not to call
after seven
why did you come here so i would tell
you that the door isn't the place for
the y
conversation because they're going to be
all gussied up like
just don't answer the door don't answer
the door yeah
yeah and then send your phone's off and
you've got your white noise machine on
you're not going to hear it anyway
and it's this i can hear it in you you
have this compulsion to make sure the
people around you
are okay that's not your job
your job is to make sure you're well and
taken care of
because you deserve it everybody does
exactly but all of us who are helpers
like to make sure everybody else is okay
because that's where we get our value
and esteem from
everyone else is okay and then we get
super annoyed when they don't have the
same respect of our lives and our
boundaries
and then it it was a big shock to me to
realize oh i'm in charge of that
i'm in charge of my boundaries of my
wellness of my taking care of me
and it's super annoying because that's
hard real
real hard and real real annoying um
so what do you do you make firm
boundaries and then you hold them
and then know that the people in your
world are gonna try to lean up against
them are they real they're gonna hold
are they real are they real
they're real they're gonna hold and
number two if they violate them
you have a direct non-apologetic i asked
you not to come over and you rang my
doorbell
till 10 o'clock last night please don't
ever do that again
i was exhausted i'm going to school
taking a break
oh my gosh we just wanted to play i'm so
sorry but it's cool i hear you
um please if i tell you i'm gonna be out
i'm gonna be out okay oh my gosh i'm so
sorry i'm i'm sorry
come on dude we're just gonna go to the
show i don't want to go to the show um
i need some sleep so thank you so much
we'll go to the show next time i'll let
you know when i'm ready to go back to
the show
and it's with a period at the end of it
um and then either they're gonna
bang their head up against your boundary
a few times and realize they don't like
you anymore which is super cool
problem solved or they're gonna honor
your boundaries and you're just going to
be that weird friend that goes to bed
early i'm that guy in my friend circle
and they're going to continue to reach
out or they're going to send you a text
and be like hey if you want to we're all
going to fill in the blank and then you
get to decide
and i love those because then i get to
decide and i go sometimes i don't go
sometimes
and i don't lie i don't make up like i'm
just not going to go
thank you or i'll be there see you there
you get to decide those boundaries
and practice having those hard direct
conversations because they're the rest
of your life anna and i'm so glad that
someone with your heart
is out there changing lives especially
being a doctor who's interested in
lifestyle change you just made my whole
heart
swell bigger and bigger than i thought
it could